we're just talking about beavis and
butt-head but instead we'll stop to talk
about Waterworld that's the show you're
watching we talked about the other show
on that another channel and then you
come here to see our thoughts behind the
film behind the honest trailer just
agree to the end you get deleted scenes
and settling a score from last week I'm
very curious to check this out yes yes
if I remember to queue it up but more
about Waterworld it's a film it is a
film it's wet it's wild fair it's
drenched you could say yeah and I
maintain that it is good despite the
fact that the hero is terrible
it's a good movie but a bad story if
that makes sense I mean to me it's it's
it's got a lot of good action beats and
Dennis Hopper is having a lot of fun and
a lot if you have the flip side of
Dennis Hopper in that role like a like a
Jack Burton yeah oh yes if you if you
did it if you had if the whole movie was
more playful like the smokers it would
be a whole lot better if you Brian to be
Jack Sparrow any jack yeah it's just I
think it's a fun certainly the action is
incredible because it's all real dammit
it's really bogged down by the miserable
era of Kevin Costner that yeah this
movie happened to come out and I'm my
rewash because I hadn't seen it since I
was probably like 15 16 younger no young
yeah younger because 95 postman came out
when I like had started high school so
yeah I was in middle school and hadn't
washed it since cuz I think even this
one I loved everything when I was a kid
and even this one I think I was like ya
know I liked it probably more as a kid
because before seeing the film
I read the novelization of water
million observations I want to live
Simon birch was based on an unpublished
chapter from the waterworld novel I got
into reading from like I think Jurassic
Park and Michael Crichton novels and so
yeah and I think because of that weirdly
I would only read a book if it also had
a movie run of this where I only wanted
to read the book like I would read ahead
like what movies are coming out next
year and then I want to read those books
the firm is Christian Christian for
middle schoolers just dipped into dad
Airport books yeah anymore now they just
play now or tonight and jerk off yeah
they don't appreciate good except here
oh yeah because yeah sorry watching it
back as an adult like in the first that
first sequence in like the cool action
scene and like he's kind of cool at the
beginning and it's kind of tense and fun
I was like wait his water world good
right there yeah it was like no I am NOT
it's got like the bones of a more fun
movie but it just never gets there cuz
it occurred to me too while rewatching
it that it's kind of a proto superhero
movie like he's he's basically a
superhero in this world yeah but it just
never gets to that point of being like
fun but makes a man to take the reigns
right it's it's but it never but it
never finds that magic it never gets to
the point where it's fun and exciting
and exhilarating to see because of the
dowry I don't say that everything else
in the film is that the smokers are that
the set pieces are that the the idea
that they would like fly in some
dirigible to Mount Everest to save the
day is a ridiculous idea yeah it's just
playing it so like miserable and Mad Max
II in a bad way that it's whatever it's
uneven train watch it let's do it this
summer we're getting honest Buster's
summer who are all these people in an
era where Michael Bay empowering
derivatives be requested and roland
emmerich blew up the world Kevin Costner
only needed one bomb to blow up
Universal in
waterworld now pause that's not fully
true I mean it it was a big bomb at the
time but let you like everything else it
makes its money back eventually
it's our ridiculed it's not even in the
top ten I don't think bombs of all time
know what I ended up doing pretty well
internationally especially if you
include international it's just that the
budget kept going up yeah so yeah it
developed this reputation for being a
huge Turkey but I feel like it was like
a proto internet thing we're like the
yeah the year leading up to it it was
like what ridiculous story we heard from
Waterworld now it was like yeah yeah
it's like that generation put in 40
quarters for Waterworld the game yeah
yeah I mean I think that used to happen
a lot with I mean it still does like
troubled productions and the movie
becomes kind of interest like Dark
Phoenix we kind of had an example like
we kind of knew before it even opened at
least the studio thought it was
disappointing but this was like
magnified cuz there was just so less so
much less information about movies
coming out when the [ __ ] sinks yeah we
lost a stuntman in the ocean yeah that
makes it into like the LA Times and
everybody reads it they're like oh man
this movie we're a hundred million
people were calling a fish star yeah did
not was not yeah anyways undeserved rep
as one of the hugest flops of all time
you don't have three stunt shows
worldwide if you're a huge flop that's
right that's right anyway spammer I keep
going enter the water see one in Japan
has Waterworld a post apocalypse where
everyone looks like they sleep in
SpongeBob's dumpster snake ship vehicles
resource hoarding warlords and here I'll
save you some time
it's Mad Max but wet
what
deals for gills we actually discussed
should we mix up the Mad Max clips like
should we show clips from the older Mad
Max movies this is clearly ripping off
because this came her fury road but then
we were like kid do kids know the old
Abed Max movies no Lord humungus they
hit the same beats in oh yeah the other
two Mad Max well three other three men
max yeah you know that's if I had never
seen a Mad Max movie and then I saw this
like when I saw this the first time yeah
it's much more impressive taking a lot
of inspiration not just inspiration
didn't they had the guy that shot
Thunderdome shoot this either
cinematographer or something either the
second one or the third one road
warriors warrior this yeah shot it to
give it that max
everybody's grimy yeah exactly yeah I
mean is there always a motion now the
yeah brainy brawny that's no one's salty
enough in this in a very salty
there's no salty dog very salt crusted
on that a toilet the smokers are very
grimy which I guess okay fine I'm just
picturing Kevin Reynolds like stalking
up and down the set with one of those
old director makeup was like right here
that extra he had to get Bryant as with
yeah yeah
Kevin Costner is the Mariner a hero with
all the charm of a guy getting hit with
a bucket of water because cold sea water
they'll say action it's like really few
words
that's his reaction yeah him in his boat
much more loving there's a lot more
concern and compassion for the boat is
both that's the biggest have you ever I
haven't but I I know people who have
owned boats and man they love those
boats yeah I mean they can go back to
land at some point imagine if you
couldn't if you just like not having a
boat in Waterworld you're the biggest
the biggest ongoing feud and my family
is way back in the day before my time my
my mom's dad was gonna sell his boat my
dad always really wanted that boat my
mom made sure he never found out about
the boat being on sale and they still
bring it up the boat relationship I
can't missed with yeah interesting fun
boat we can pause for boat talk because
it I feel like people usually regret
boats like there's a lot of boat lust
and then once you catch the boat and you
really are like oh now I have to pay all
this boat maintenance there's something
wrong with the boat as you can see from
Waterworld he always needs resin he
always needs supplies a special person
to really love that boat like fully
commit to boat life yeah there's a
casual boat owner which is frustrating
cuz I feel like it took more paperwork
for me to adopt a cat then it probably
does for jerks like that to buy a boat
yes immediately discard the boat if you
live close to where the boating happens
you love your boat it's those people
from like the city two hours away
they don't really know I'm positive
Potok keep going around
but this mysterious printer has a mutant
power of being super good at rope stuff
there's always a rope nearby always
every action let me just start looking
more than even on a sailboat as you can
see there gropes everywhere good Windham
and that sound effect applause I got
this fish man had us watching on a
mission to save a girl from the only guy
in the movie who knows how silly it is
he had a great run of way on the top
villains learn to do the right thing kid
we got a pitch over the side eventually
[Music]
any time now right after this
the nineties didn't deserve you Jeanne
Tripplehorn a lot of her roles yeah off
with Dennis Hopper at least they get a
jet ski so take a shot of hydro top off
your go choose a freehand
post-apocalypse jump change us the boat
Caston well you know things obtained may
have been the laughingstock of Hollywood
for being an expensive set sinking
vanity project
but still had the seat of something
really cool you just cut out all the
terrible dialogue the characters the
story and I want to Rose starring her
man dad mum and me as soon as I'm home
from work my right there's a great when
I was trying to recollect like okay what
were all the weird-ass stories about
this movie I found a great oral history
that is the director Jeanne Tripplehorn
the girl I care about major even thing
yeah and then just Jack the whole thing
Jack Black is really fun kisses he's a
nothing thing in the very Lincoln you'll
miss it there just like was it uh was it
challenging working with uh with Costner
do you remember and he and he's just
like no complete pro-pro would do it
again they never really have a scene
together did not meet on this set yeah
all of his answers are just like one two
words he's also got a great memory and
blink and you miss it appearance in Mars
Attacks Jack yeah like in almost he's
also the villain in neverending story
three Wow he's also the
- Elodie that is worse than the records
half of the band Tenacious D he's Kung
Fu Panda when I get back to Chin's
what our chicks their shells right ho
that would be like inflation like shells
are everywhere more than an extra that
mean is this like when Robin Williams
passes you get him like just go real
full mana the fact that Kim Coates has
never played Robin anything is shocking
what if it's not girl paper I could see
him doing that he's great it's nice to
see somebody coming in and really just
like doing the most was like everyone
else is doing the most parts except for
your dour hero your dour wet fish over
here yeah it's just like he thought this
was gonna be like another like JFK and
it's like no no this is silly you're an
ocean you gotta save the girl like
because the account is he wanted to be a
swashbuckler swashbuckler director keV
was like no this is a dark gritty thing
right but I also don't based on every
other thing I've ever seen Kevin Costner
do yeah I don't know how fun and
adventurous he sees swashbuckler Robin
Hood yeah it's just done merriness where
it protects you the the postman isn't
that exciting to be never done just like
big goofy can't be fun Kevin Costner
movie like as close as he gets is when
he does like the sports move like tin
cup yeah yeah this a lot more fun Bull
Durham and tin cup and that embarrassing
never seen him go like full Errol Flynn
right now no okay even as a young man no
always been sign my fan petition to
remake Waterworld with a Jack Black oh
my god yes
no should I have
should we do a sequel where he's
reprising his role from the first round
it's like what did that smoker do after
that Valdez sunk well I was talking
about wasn't I saying it was it to you
today about how I would LARP if it were
Waterworld yeah yeah I'll go down to the
beach floating like a floaty atoll out
of there's a playable thank you remember
what it's called but like summer near
Joshua Tree there is like a
post-apocalyptic town and they all
everybody knows their max cosplay right
and I for a week okay ever but I
definitely think they need to it'll be
way more fun yeah they need to do the
atoll they need to expand I just want a
guy when you show up you're not allowed
to use money you just have to bring dirt
but there's a guy that takes what are
you tasting for any fan that guy doesn't
think that this is for funsies
collecting there all the time
I love the realism thank God yeah wild
wild wet finish the Mariner may have
taught her to swim but Napoleon Dynamite
taught her to LA I'm girl I blew my mind
you would think there would be more I'm
all surprised one thing I was like
keeping notes on cuz I was convinced
would come up a bunch is like
environmental messages alterations in
the 90s before we gave up this error
right we didn't give it up and just
surrendered to let the oceans retake us
a movie about the polar ice caps melting
flooding the whole world and you can
mention it like three times if you like
really not a very environment right on
top and then right near the end when I
do find out oh it's the Exxon Valdez and
then there's like one like Michael Jeter
has one line like oh what did the
ancient humans do to ruin the planet but
that's it otherwise it's purely just
like business what happened well you
know in that's too much in my opinion
but like you know
most movies especially from this era
that made it there would be a lot of
like speechify like oh those humans
couldn't figure out how to organize
themselves
Costard crossed out yeah the Mariner was
supposed to say those lines yeah and he
was like what if just I didn't say what
I said my boat in the ancients done like
truly they rejected this blessed earth
days like I'm just glad the movie
expresses the idea that like look we're
screwing over the earth without needing
to get into it it's a real Joe don't
tell ya it's surprising it would be a
lot more heavy-handed yeah I was reading
that if all of the ice caps melt every
single of them that the water would it
would rise like 750 feet so I'm like
that's no book which is bad which is not
good yeah we're terrible but like we'd
have more than Everest to live on you
know all kinds of mountains we could
huddle up salvaging the key made by two
guys who hate each other they store each
other
sipar barren earth kevin Cousteau the
ocean in the ocean ocean 11 pepper water
kumar's and piranhas smoker and the
bandits cuz that Jack Black
yep and tenacious Inconvenient Truth
three mariner right
Mad Max fury boat yawns shudder note the
watery world and finger blaster and
would someone just take Kevin sperm
already take Kevin swing there's a
Snyder cut of Waterworld
yes world this is real we did not do the
expanded cut unfortunately because I
remember like seeing Mount Everest in
the film so so I did some reading yeah
oh boy and there was the theatrical cut
and then like a Berenstein bear thank
einde of happened where when it came out
for TV it was like 30 minutes longer I
think mouth I think there was a ton more
footage like the the Everest thing and
there was like a lot more smoker stuff
than like I have more time being spent
on the Valdez before the rescue
operation like when we just this past
time we were watching it it goes real
quick she gets taken there and then all
of a sudden she's like he's gonna come
get me and you get the scene of him
breaking in yeah yeah there definitely
was more of like how they go about their
day to day smoker lives yeah and which
thank God
yeah I need to hear it for my life to
get into character we that no more Hey
but yeah so there was that and then some
dude this is way back in the day some
guy like there were different cuts
depending on where it was syndicated and
some guy like pulled them all together
and just one thing he called the Ulises
cut yes yeah and I think that's what the
blu-ray is and that man was Kevin
Reynolds
yeah with all the squares in the violin
the iliad that is that a reference he's
on him he's on that's another one of the
cutscenes as she names him at the end
she named him Ulysses I remember that
from the book no because I oh right did
we yeah I remember we had a false start
and then the video broke how do they
know that reference what so paper that
was on the paper he he's sold sold her
buttocks collar reading the classics
oral tradition you know I say okay we be
telling our kids about you I'll tell my
children of the Mariner yes amazing one
last thing we wanted to leave you with
our intrepid editor in heaven if you
recall last week we ended on a semen
joke how appropriate a/c man say man
talking about the Jackson Pollock line
from guardians of the galaxy and he
maintained that there was like a
squishing noise that you could hear when
he walks around the Milano and we all
went now that's disgusting I can't
believe they would do that seems like
Disney would put the kibosh I catch that
but we're gonna roll the clip and you
decide if you hear star-lord
stepping in his own to the line no it's
pretty far after because it could be
like there's just a rapper or train one
more time we have to stop Ronan Wow
I hope you're all listening with
headphones anyways I like it
you you you chew on that for for a week
and we'll discuss next time you know
what I think Disney right to fire him
thank you Kevin for bringing that to our
attention and thank you for watching
next week we'll be back the clue to next
week is in the title the fake title of
this week mmm check it out we'll see you
at movies tonight
[Music]
you